分
今日はどうで始めた皆さん玉ねぎ見てるとなるが出るのをご存知でしょうか
ラスボーンですねお母様の夜版を作るのてった時に玉ねぎ知ってる涙がすごい出たん
ですよあれなぜ涙がでるかと言いますと言うかアリルという物質のせいらしいですね
包丁などで玉ねぎを切ると玉ねぎの細胞が壊れてその壊れたせいで硫化アリルって言う
のができちゃう
でそれが鼻とか目の粘膜に付いちゃうと審議が涙を流せて
なるらしいんですよねまぁこ守るためにそれで自然と涙が出ちゃうっていうのがでいい
なシーンですけどもうね私の形に行ってきた中で涙なんてまあ流すものの創作さんなが
減るもんじゃないと思うんですよ
伝世がこの化学現象を使えば1リットルぐらいの涙だったら出せるんじゃないかなと
いまして
映画みたいですね相当側ねゲ必要かなと思ってちょっと玉ねぎたくさん準備してそして
こちらに1リットルのボトルを準備しました私人間はこれを一リットルの涙でいっぱい
にするにどれくらい時間がかかるのでしょうか涙絶対出ちゃうんで無理ではないと思う
んですよ
愛知でてるの涙って言うあるくらいですからまあ短期間で1リットルもなく人も他の子
のようにそういないと思うんですよね米系素敵だ瞬間
になるのではないかと思っておりますエヴァ以降まずジャズしまうんねうん
水飲んででたぞと怪しいですけど早速頑張って性と思いましています
4位同センターまでにまで切ってみますねカートナムジャバリ料理したことないんです
よねこのって i まずはタマネギを切るとグークアリルが発生し涙が出るはずです
[音楽]
出てくればもうちょっと切るか
若干きましたねー
[音楽]
あああああすっもうもう1回も来た滝田
たらしっかりとドロップにしないとダメなんで
[音楽]
予約入ってき入りました行ってきでるのに3分50秒かかってますこれ頑張ろう
滝のような涙を流さ顎から落とす作戦します
鼻水出ちゃう
[音楽]
あー五月天 air ここで取れる取れあああ
あー胃が痛いですやはりはえまってこれああ
[音楽]
ban
う yeah 痛いよ
マーナ別の場所に落ちてるしてこんなにいるっていうまた難しいですねぇ
[音楽]
増えちゃった矢部は甘みが出れば落とせない滝のように流れたらここで凍ってるんです
けどなかなか滝のような涙まで意見ですねそれでどんどん流カールに出さなきゃいけ
ないんで玉ねぎ向いてきます
[音楽]
さあなさせてくれよはこの俺を産ん数字おしっこ位すごい
涙で村などで出るもんじゃないからなぁ
[音楽]
me
ピガール web や絵図は酒は飢えたまで議員の涙でで効果と味目の感動するシーン
の創造コカですごい伸び高でまずは言えるからちょっとたまりますねやば様だけ足り
ないで頑張らず
[音楽]
8倍でないよなんだ慣れてきた気がしました目がもっと頑張ります
もっとえお年だった[ __ ]
[音楽]
me
ああああああああ
[音楽]
だめだやばいべなくなりました命が耐性ついていたのかわかんないけど痛いだけだが
玉ねぎロス利用したり一に切ったりみじん切りしたりいろんなすぐやってきたんです
けどもどれも効果がなくなってきました
[音楽]
でもせはいと言うわけでえっと1時間近くやってみたんですけども no
涙が枯れましたもう出ませんあと玉ねぎ切ってもなんか効果が薄くなってきた気がする
んじゃないよね薄くなってて来ただ俺の涙はなくなっただけかもしれないもう泣けませ
んただた元系が痛いです痛いと眼球が直に挙げるとめっちゃ目へたくて普通にこの1
時間苦しかったですはいておいで結論カレーと多分一致 l 出すのは無理前に蓄積し
ていければ出来
ゆうとんですけどもけっこうすごいぞ何を見て泣いたりもするんですけど一応1時間で
惚れくらいの涙はたまりましたね
結構よ湖周3 l くらい出てる気がしますね
いやめっちゃないんだと思うよこれ普通にはいというわけで今回の事件では勝ったらと
タマネギを切ると5リットルは泣けない涙は金心も乾き眼球は痛いみんな真似するなよ
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ